greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of it's happening now is brought to you
by hims listen 66% of men lose their
hair by the age of 35 thing is when you
start to notice the hair loss it's too
late so it's easy to keep the hairdo you
got then to replace the hair you've lost
now listen hims connects you with real
doctors and medical grade solutions that
treat hair loss for hims dot-com a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men all right now do
me a favor today if you order now today
the church family gets a trial month of
hymns for just five dollars while
supplies last see the website for full
detail this will cost hundreds of
dollars if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy go to hims comm slash Joey
that's for hims fo r hims comm slash
Joey
alright go there and take care your
little hair loss or whatever all the
problems you may have all right and this
is the real deal hims
number two listen you heard me talk
about me on these and you know I'm a big
believer in the product I think they're
the best they're comfortable they keep
you dry they keep you not second tip top
Magoo or I'm 55 so nothing could do that
but anyway listen to me me on these you
got 100% money-back guarantee honey
percent satisfaction guarantee me on
these guarantee you'll love their on
these or your money back
alright now me and this has a great
offer for the church family for the
first time purchases when you purchase
me on these you'll get one p percent off
and free shipping ed on the percent
satisfaction guarantee to get 20% off
your first pair free shipping and one
hundred-percent money-back satisfaction
guarantee go to me on these coms last
Joey again
that's me undies dot-com slash Joey kick
that [ __ ] mewling oh [ __ ] yeah I hope
everybody had a great weekend welcome to
the Church of what's happened now the
[ __ ] full effect but my
brother's here tonight to talk to you
people but some [ __ ] my main man
whatever his funk friend that's up my
boy you know fine put the pieces
together I got a busy week [ __ ]
when you've been busy dog now you know
what bar I'd do it
slice and slow and nobody gets their
feelings hurt I get to spend time with
the family
yeah I get to put my efforts into the
pot gasps I take the cake to take care
of myself
my smarter Road when we were talking
about something really interesting we I
know I forgot two of us all about
Roseanne Barr
oh yeah Rosen I don't know I don't know
why she's getting [ __ ] now I don't he'll
keep up on poor Roseanne now whenever
the [ __ ] the dealer her ratings are up
there though oh yeah killing of the
biggest I think was ABC's biggest
premiere in the decade or something like
that it was huge it was like 18 million
people or someone like that you know
it's [ __ ] weird that we were talking
about when she shot this pressure at the
store and uh-huh it's he sure told very
waken and knowing that's not to talk to
her yeah and they talked the way she
told the [ __ ] off
yo it's you have no idea what Roseanne
Barr was doing at that time here was
this this has to be 97 when I got hit 97
Roseanne Barr was tearing these
[ __ ] up and if it wasn't
Roseanne Barr it was the other chick
from the south remember they caught her
she'll quit night in the episodes I'm
you remember this in my head a median
chick she never recovered from that she
still does gay couple years ago I
thought she was gonna go on the road
girl iliza shlesinger and some other
chicks but something happens she's too
far gone
they gave her a show and she [ __ ] him
left the planet to know that the hell
other side of the world when you saw
your soul like that it gets dark nikodem
you start acting weird but Roseanne like
I saw great interview years ago and
Larry King you know you know when you
get home from the comedy gigs you know
hotel room whatever's on this island you
and sometimes it's something interesting
it was Roseanne and I was sitting there
going over the nights like oh you're
your jokes in the night where you [ __ ]
up what joke didn't work like that [ __ ]
I had a bag of nachos you know you got a
soul to have just relaxing just
unwinding but she did a great interview
where she spoke about they asked her
about the Cosby's oh they said well
specifically they asked her why she
threw out the brass maybe see from a
Christmas party Oh who's the brass like
all the toppy from ABC Roseanne wouldn't
I'm in town Christmas party no way Fah
like she was that powerful like when she
knocked Cosby Donnell from Thursday
night them that Poirot Zant or different
that was another level
she got [ __ ] crazy and that was she
was fine right as when I got here they
were fine riders it was always something
going on yeah well we'll the show was
done by that time but the attitude was
huge and over the years she humble I
mean she's worth billions of thought
yeah
but at the store Joey was like does she
come in strong or does she get strong
there she came into the store glowing
heat oh she was a character inside a
character the story goes that she was in
the original room it's he sought made a
do a set in the main room and the people
in it the night show her that you know
hold the ear on tomorrow all the day
ever oh wow like that's how fast it
moved her in those days The Tonight Show
was the Joe Rogan experience yeah you
did The Tonight Show you did well you
got worked on that today it was that
[ __ ] easy
whether it's one time at 10:00 he was
still on JRE bitching I'm saying yeah
yeah that's a million downloads a
million people know about what you do
with that million downloads is up to you
now yes attack those million people do
you lay back and just what people gonna
come see me people don't pay attention
to me so there wasn't that Roseanne
handle every Roseanne was [ __ ] huge
bro but back to Larry King
she told Larry King that ABC came to her
and they said our dream is for you to
knock off column E so she fired all her
writers and everybody started from
scratch jack and she got two riders and
she makes them with two stand-up
comedians
oh it's just brilliant mix and she let
them battle without her room and she
executive produced you know she made the
husband Tom Arnold yeah him on the show
oh yeah let me off huh no no she had
Goodman still on but something has
something I don't know that was a
brother I don't [ __ ] know what
happened Tom Arnold was smooth bag is
smooth Tom Waddell played it like a
fiddle walked out of there with 15
million dollars Kardashian Kardashian
it's [ __ ] amazing what he did but
Roseanne was huge but the attitude was
even bigger like the attitude
was big Broadway [ __ ] walking off
stage is [ __ ] but she had so much dough
it didn't matter and she had power right
it's yet power and what how many women
shows do you think I've been out before
Roseann came out with that heat I don't
know I just remember I Love Lucy rolling
yeah yeah you can't [ __ ] him I Love Lucy
and I'm a Mary Tyler Moore sure I don't
know about how big she came out but I
just know that I started in Denver and
she came out of Denver so was our
starting comedy Roseanne was [ __ ]
killin hating off so Denver became a
hotbed for stand-up everybody moved to
Denver now oh I've had the recipe
comedians think that way
I started in death that's where I lived
I lived in Boulder so I had to start in
Denver when I went down there once I got
into the scene little by little
you heard rumblings the old the comics
all pissed off she stole my job yeah I
wrote for her yeah everybody wrote for
her all the silent ones they didn't make
it yeah everybody was pissed off at her
so half the camp and then the loved her
but the other half of camp didn't
[ __ ] like him because he either stole
their jokes or he wrote for it she
didn't pay him there was always and all
that shit's just [ __ ] Howard
Youkilis everybody
let me tell you something he has a comic
if Lee gave me five jokes a month like
the room with why would I get rid of
little it's different yeah deals and
yeah I know exactly what you say I run
white hires five comics to write from so
does Kevin Hart yeah there's people on
laptops I seen his shoulders people are
laptops hey homie stop stop
dude it again dawg yeah that's Anna she
make a living
yeah a good comic knows he gets three on
the comics then he's like I love HBO
gives me three love dolls I'm Paul and
Chris Rock oh yeah I'm taking three
Columbus I like know his 50,000 a piece
until I shoot the special you're with me
every night we're hanging out every
night pick me up at 7:45 every night
we're gonna know able to drive us around
Wow you're prob the haha
and you're writing Louise writing and
somebody else is writing each get 50
grand damn I'm so so referred that's
Chris Rock style I invent that Chris
Rock did that oh why did that would Nick
DiPaolo Lewis CK and Richard Jeni oh wow
thinking uh that's why if you watched
Chris Rock's early specials did ya fire
you gave everybody 50 or 75 and said 15
15 15 15 takes the pressure off me yeah
plus [ __ ] do what you do do
what you do web and how you on a web it
and they be outside the store talking no
put it here that put it brother they be
right there and they'd start at the
improv 20 Laugh Factory gets five
welcome [ __ ] do 20 and
sometimes one of them will go up Chris
Rock would go up and Richard Jeni would
go back and do this joke let me work it
this way that's how badass they were Wow
so I'm walking in there with joy Perez
Lee and not only we walking in more
going up and you're gonna try the
material you roll for me and you're
gonna try to joke you row for me and
then go ooh when I was on stage I [ __ ]
it up man yeah do it this way and add
Joey to it now put [ __ ] there boom we
got a joke you're 75,000 you're 50,000
is worth wait and go now the comic to
have his ego lowered by doing that yeah
you don't lower my ego to me
you're [ __ ] telling me Joey I'm
putting my life in your hands yeah I'm
gonna take camera go what week you need
me get off the road I'll be right there
which every there's a way to do this is
six seven nights a week three spots
during the week and on the weekend take
a man down spend some time with your
family it's 15 the 16 spots a week we
just happen to be gonna bomb on purpose
just to talk now you just want to talk
and get a line yeah one of these guys
got a tape recorder boom we got that
line dawg all right now use email Italy
email he emails at the [ __ ] giant la
Bamba and by the morning
we got three [ __ ] jokes from that
that's real try out that's how you do it
yeah plus the camp stays fed like
[ __ ] are happy because I paid
now nobody says well he wrote my joke I
wrote a joke nobody says now
[ __ ] that [ __ ] baby soon [ __ ]
we've before like as a fan when we
talked about this before III was really
not against it cuz I like but it's I if
I always imagined if I was a stand-up I
would never let any like I wouldn't want
people to write for me like they'd see I
like people who wrote for themselves but
like you said something like you can
give me a rise here and there like one
thing he said is just your material is
like how your world collides with that
or way that's the world and like so III
don't even see it really as writing it's
like because it's like we were talking
about specials and how like when people
do a few specials they kind of run out
of material almost like you're just
writing for so long so if some if
someone else is just like kind of like
lobbing it up for you and then you like
like Joey if you were hiring us if we
gave you an idea you probably change it
a little bit you'd adapt it to your
point of view but it's just no no but
see the people are you hiring you get
open mics with right they know you for
the last 15 years okay they know how to
write to you they know how to write for
you it's not just anybody but the
friends I bonded with them you you Fiji
for me I'm gonna time bro we did that
Club for $16 an ad - yeah that's
remember remember when we did cool he
was like I've had thousands of people
that I've known over the years I go bro
I wrote of something it's not working
but I see your name uh-oh it's different
it's different yeah some people do it
from the heart
some people do it on the way before they
hang on think appropriately work throw
of my way yeah I think it was a bad joke
as [ __ ] healing so you call me with a
bad joke man you won't work [ __ ] your
resume was weak you know saying well
it's the truth it really is the truth
that no rose rose and doing that
Roseanne had in Denver I don't [ __ ]
know I don't I didn't check the facts
all I know is the right guy got on stage
in Denver everything everything every
time you went to a room with six comics
they talked about two cars
Roseanne Barr and Sinbad why what was
Sinbad supposedly lived in done
and he did better he did a benefit one
time and a bunch of Jochen but my cooks
went to the benefit you know had to be
open my Korean huh and Sinbad said to
these open Michaels they said tip Mac
give her some advice and Sinbad was like
listen what I need you guys to do is to
write clean calm and stay away from
there any comedy cuz you want to be
universal all this show like this so all
those dudes became anti dirty so just
like Rogen and Boston last started in
Denver everybody was brought you to
dirty my Gish it's too dirty and dirty
like that three said three [ __ ] week as
everybody was trying to be [ __ ]
Sinbad yeah it's so weird how the heroes
from the area define you you know I'm
saying you have to figure out what they
did what was different like when you
read the Sam Kinison book it's a great
read because it tells about Sam in
Houston would call a ball and bill hex
which is irreplaceable that's what
comedy is all about you getting to the
top with your friends you know when your
friends are then you could go back and
go broke them but Casa latina on Tuesday
night he'll these locks come on people
gonna follow the hours what are you
talking about because everybody thinks
we just met we've been doing comedy for
three years yeah they don't understand
that I know you so [ __ ] two or
something 98 99
you know me since o2o 303 and we've met
each other we gave me to respect for
each other because we saw each other in
all the [ __ ] hell holes around LA
where guys wouldn't step foot into those
[ __ ] day now most people wouldn't
step foot into those things me and the
inside even back then I knew they would
make me better and there were a pain in
the ass to do they were pain the [ __ ] it
has to do cuz there's always a Laker
game on logic a mother and now you you
know you're doing four spots so one of
your spots is late that's [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up yeah
so once one of your spots is late then
we go for the money
where's the money at that's who gets my
attention yeah that free one and Melrose
see you later bye cuz I'm not gonna make
it goodnight
yeah but you're headlining come on my
father's here he came from Maine I don't
give a [ __ ] get some money I was at the
improv I'm Georgia pick up an envelope
yeah I should give you a hundred bucks
out papi oh yeah a big [ __ ] to make
[ __ ] people are like one of the things
that really frazzled me before I moved
to LA and this is for anybody who's
moving in general for whatever
occupation whenever I would speak to
people like if you're a dancer or you're
a [ __ ] archaeologist or whatever
people always shy you away like whenever
I would mention LA when I was a feature
on triple runs on shitty comedy rooms
uh-huh the headliner was usually a
failed that way coming yes who either
told you that you want some dick to be
in LA you gotta be gay to get away or
you're not gonna get spots he's not
gonna make any money yeah it was the
weirdest thing Lee how many people told
me I was making money and it was the
opposite
yeah I saw know where your sailor and
you just have to make money you have to
know eight people who have a room and
don't throw your 50 bucks here yeah and
then you put something together and you
put them on lineup and next thing you
know you're part of network yeah and
you're part of people calling you're
gonna double you don't Tuesday night I
got $50 gig for you at bar lunch at a
and there's somebody else called you
says I gotta fit on again what do I do
hold on when they call you back what
tell me you put me up I borrow shochet
put you up at 9:15 what time is your
show I'll put you about 10:30 they're
both lines here that both line tell you
he's gonna put you up at [ __ ] these
tongue in 1915 because he's putting you
up at a quarter to 10:00 what anyone
because Joey's known to come late yeah
[ __ ] it and the other dude and the other
dude is really gonna put you up at 11:15
but you're already got a 12 with the
storm and you ain't cancel nothing nope
no whether it's 15 unless I needed that
package badly then I can i push the
store back a little bit listen I'll be
there a little way
now I remember like when I first started
a comedy Edwin San Juan had a lot of
rooms in Philippe and I was in a meeting
with them because we were just like
smoking weed I think we went to Philippe
his house when he's live on tempo on
Boylston by that high school and [ __ ]
where he lived like it was up a hill and
Philippe is like a fool check it out
Joey needs to pay rent this month dawg
so George you got him on Wednesday
Casa latina Tuesday I got him a wild
coyote a big homie we got a hell we got
him already yes mom and it was decided
you said it looks like you said it was
ways yeah it was [ __ ] crazy how I'll
never forget when I realized I was
making money when I didn't have it no
more oh yeah because from 2000 I gotta
say from 2001
if I'm lying t I'm dying right here in
front of you guys from 2001 to 2006 I
was making 400 a week as a comic during
the week you damned but that's actually
not bad I gotta remember that then you
guys started booking improv and then up
the alley for everybody yeah like what's
the in sparks are we giving this
Tuesdays and Wednesdays and some
Thursdays that changed again yeah that
automatically put money in your pocket
now constantly
now again you like Joey 304 it's really
fun to do it are two spots at night what
I should do in the store ain't that bad
when you first get here
no 1500 a month Jack I did a lot with
1,600 a month in those days you make
that [ __ ] work jack Wonder Bread Robins
you make that [ __ ] work jack a Chinese
lunch special 595 with a free soda whoo
humming humming no you make it work but
I never forget in 2007 the economy
[ __ ] one out the window I got clean
so when I got locked up yeah I got clean
off coke and all those rooms went down
the hill yeah and I was sitting there
with my dick in my hand going bro why am
I so broke it was because I was making
three to four hundred a week Tuesday not
Monday true [ __ ] Thursday or Friday
cool little gigs for these guys even
Cetina paid you small for yeah even
sateen upon us sold out sold out she'll
give me the small 40 you were picking up
envelopes all night long at the end of
the night you were looking at 160 in
your pocket you're not getting rich that
is Vera five spots right that's for spa
you got a figure you with the Comedy
Store 1560 from George 150
pay you know it's 175 but guess what
Thursday night you're only making a 65
you got a spot at the store and you got
a $50 gig up at Universal and you got to
figure out how to pay for pop [ __ ] you
better hope he pays for your parking
because it's a small 35 yeah because you
got to pay 15 for parking over here
versus yeah the small 3581 time I was at
this club called wile coyote and it's
[ __ ] gangster Lee it's gangster club
like the women in there are packing g's
and Felipe's holstein and he's like yeah
joy Dee's is closing the short and I
Joey shows up the show goes total 12
Joey shows up at 10:30 I'm headlining at
10:30 doc those days don't add the
ignition yeah I was hooked on coke I
need this money I gotta get out of here
wow I've been waiting all day to do a
[ __ ] line of coke I'm having a 10:30
yeah I get that
Filipa ghouls damn after tonight a lot
of comas are gonna say that Joey you
opened up for there me but you know what
man those are some great [ __ ] times
Joey because like Adar I'm not here to
like to kiss your ass [ __ ] but I seen
your whole evolvement it all day yeah
yeah nobody watching yours is crazy
because like you were already power but
like I could see like there's just
something wasn't letting you get in dog
like you were at the strip club in the B
I'm in the VIP room but that dick wasn't
getting hard for some [ __ ] reason and
then it was just it was over it was over
like I remember getting out of prison
and you were to say damn Georgia I was
gonna [ __ ] start selling cars cuz when
I got out of prison I was like I need
money I opened up all these rooms again
and you told me me and Rizal start to
take you and I just I just seen this
evolved and I was like oh [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] weird but I know what you mean I
see my involvement a little bit too I
see him no I saw it the last time you
want stage a red banner so I'm like a
[ __ ] George man trying this is years
this is you know spots every night and
says repetitive as there as the sounds I
don't think likely knows please hurdle
you think only danke
deena not the first two times but after
we got him drunk yeah I put a Mexican
check yeah bro if the show opens at 80
billion 8:03 ha ha how am I was there
yeah we would be there because it was a
[ __ ] open bar yeah food oh nice
anything she's good not bad yeah and if
you got there early they would eat chips
salsa plus there was done - chubby
Mexican chicks we loves them that's bar
is that spot still going on and yeah and
dirty horse yeah Ernie horse dog with
kids and husbands at home so straight
dick in the parking lot you can great
great and waitresses that were down down
awk
this is crazy leave the stories I could
pay what about the rule who booked all
what a [ __ ] book that rule that we
won on Wednesday and the following
Wednesday somebody got shot that's my
room no the Marty Moran oh yeah that one
off a telegram
oh [ __ ] I remember that [ __ ] where they
shot the dude it doesn't matter that
sounds like the deal but the funny thing
was the newsstand was back the next day
with bad days and they had flowers and
candles right before the bomb in a place
where a guy just got shot the day before
this is what we put up with them you
don't see straight up like this is you
don't know what it's like to walk past a
Mexican candle [ __ ] factory with
flowers and toys yeah I just called a
hurry last weekend and you walk in this
bar ocean there was a little stage with
half [ __ ] the sparkle okay yeah
sparkles but it was on like a 70s 80s
vibe in that pan that had the thing that
said oceans and you supposed to be on a
boat it looked like the bar that she
don't have yeah and looking at the bar
Pacino had and Carlito's Way that's what
it looked like guys I swear to God they
were trying to make this bar look like a
[ __ ] inside of a boat it was
hilarious but the night I walked in
there and I saw the flowers on the side
on my bro my comedy career better do
something because I'm doing comedy in a
place where I got
and years earlier people don't remember
when downing college threw a knife at it
no she decided no way like some dude was
life throws in the room he'll tell you
next time you tell him I was with them
Friday time to tell you about his side
this had to be 2001 mm I was in Union
yeah Diamond was very sweet then yeah
like Dan was drinking tea [ __ ] oh yeah
some poor [ __ ] through a life I
had him though he was pale for four days
meet you I'm help for his ginger
Oceanside now Oceanside's nice now I
should check I mean I don't know I
haven't been there in a while but Joey
you know I've always wanted to ask you
this man up you're like a god in the old
Latin world scene and I remember like I
hit you up I go hey dawg I'm gonna go do
a show in Visalia
you're like doc how much of the pain I'm
fine how do you like that is to be a
fifteen hundred dollar check for this
dog like how like back in like in the
90s land comedy came out Ken locals
right we're talking about this nice dog
how was it because like when I got there
I heard everybody [ __ ] like I had to
go out of my way to [ __ ] like like how
how was it what do you mean like I heard
the rooms were just jumping back then
had a taco truck outside margaritas like
you guys were doing thousand Cedars when
I first came here the Latin comedy
movement was in full effect the fact I
snuck in through the Latin comedy
movement because all three clubs had a
Latino oh alright the story had a Latino
night Sunday nights from 8 to 10 or
something Monday nights and The Improv
was big okay The Improv was well
produced the dude who did it was a
manager oh he had a couple comedians
like not big-time comics like people on
TV okay he had TV hey actors what the
[ __ ] am I saying convenience
he had actors
Cuban dude and he was a very sweet dude
he was married to a black chick that had
like one of those diseases she was a
[ __ ] soul of God that's awesome and I
came to this town and I [ __ ] did his
thing and I think he was cubed that's
why he was I come back next week but he
does don't come to my stage or other
Sudan what ya dog he was like I need for
you to pull of Sudan that's some wack
[ __ ] til I thought about it and I
thought about it I thought about it like
that and I was like and I go to [ __ ] him
at a cancer spot at the improv I went to
Melrose
I bought a secondhand black suit that's
how broke I was I just bought it [ __ ]
you don't do it I'm committed to that
suit I bought the suit and I'm weekly
and I got a call then I'm opening up I'm
doing a show at the desert and this is
the desert it was open words words the
desert in Vegas exactly it's good they
saw [ __ ] but the desert was one of the
old-school casinos the Mafia ran but
they were doing comedy that no and it
was me David towel oh I'm like louis c.k
see 1,500 bucks dog that was the biggest
gig of my life I'm ready for this I get
that everybody canceled so guess who
replaced them holy favorito and Tim
Allen Oh
when Tim Allen was Tim Allen Dan I think
the [ __ ] that sitting in the room right
now for nothing Vegas and Kevin Hart
walks and he goes going I'm doing gig
with you but they don't even know it
damn people the audience didn't even
know Tim Allen was there so I went out
first I broke Vinny up really brought
Tim out the place nearly erupted
afar that's how I became friends with
Tim Allen he was telling me that he's
doing this he doesn't want nobody to
know his business mm-hmm he doesn't want
people to come to watch him that's
that's so [ __ ] smooth dokey Kevin
when I suck right now but I just want to
do stand-up but nobody gets that does
everybody I call says we may end it now
he feels they have to put your name on
the gazebo so he was doing spots over at
the Laugh Factory in the 9897
but he would pop in he didn't want them
to know what he was coming up because
they would advertise him huh he got
busted for cocaine huh yeah before he's
from Detroit yes that's crazy
sorry go ahead
yeah I just trip out because like if you
if you look at the comics like a dog I'm
finally not judging people like I used
to judge people like if we're locked up
on the street ah you know [ __ ] this food
I don't like the way this will eats you
know what I mean I used to judge people
like that and I stop judging people like
that and in my head I was going Joey D
has been locked up Tim Allen been locked
up your seas been locked up
Toby Higgs been locked up how many
comedians have been locked up there's
not that many of us dawg
i'ma tell you the truth okay so I got it
to come in 91 for like a year I just did
comedy and then something sparked me
renting videos how's the share one ups
this video store had three floors in
Boulder they were the biggest video in
the store in the [ __ ] state of
Colorado or some and he upstairs was
just comedy there was a wall just
stand-up comedy everybody was like oh
and one of the tapes I brought home one
day it was Tim Allen on the Showtime
all-stars and dog I [ __ ] laugh my ass
off that two days before he goes to the
dentist he don't brush his teeth I
hadn't heard that bad eat Oreo Shores
1980 [ __ ] 7/10 but before he goes to
dentist he would eat Oreos a pack sour
cream and there's Hollywood stick so
when he'd open his mouth the bird would
fly out of it just stupid [ __ ] bro I
thought it was amusing and I and I'll
never forget that did some reading up
all of it I can't lie to anybody my
heart melted when I found out Tim Allen
had done time and he was a rat he'll
tell you well away he ran he ran sorry I
can't kick a wooden something it was a
mistake but he didn't want to do time he
really he had already started doing
stand-up or something but when I read
that he did time and got a deal from
Disney it made me a relief like he gave
me a breathing room my camel yeah but
they won't give it to us I know yeah
you're right but now I know it's okay
listen before any network gives us
anything
do a background check yeah before you
invest in you they're gonna do a
background check
what are they gonna find out that
background check George they're gonna
find a lot of [ __ ] for me ain't [ __ ] for
you but as long as you don't stick your
fingers in the kids [ __ ] drugs to the
kid you don't beat your wife you can
judge yeah
and I'm quite on none of that school I'm
cool with that [ __ ] so what uh what you
have to feel you made a mistake in 1987
you paid for it and you went on with
your life that's what the story is that
they look at my background check
yeah I had a couple coming kidnap the
[ __ ] and he's showing up next this
weekend in Tempe oh yeah ten fellas
coming to the table on Friday night
you're getting your tweet cleared right
that's that's what's up Don it's that
bro if you judge a Bliss's this is why I
don't like this lady [ __ ] that's
somebody molested me in 89
someone molested you no I'm sorry that
this lay this [ __ ] listen to George
molested me last night let's call the
police right now I'm sure that
everything is all right
but for you to come out and say right
now that I feel you're know Tommy still
in 2001 one night some chick just come
out of the blue you got a call from the
[ __ ] police going there coming
over the house George Perez hey dawg and
they lock on the door and they sit you
down make a listen some [ __ ] lady just
came to the station for last three days
and said then mm - you were at tortillas
forcefully bass bars the Joey Diaz and
you took her in the back and you forced
her to have anal sex and right now what
what's stopping
what's stopping anybody from doing yeah
that's the [ __ ] up [ __ ] so when you
look at if you look if you do a
background check on me you're gonna find
a kidnap I've been pleaded down I pled
down they wouldn't [ __ ] play it down
they wouldn't play down with non violent
okay okay right my bad I thought it was
like no it was haven't grabbed her go
was heavy-duty boy at the end of the day
know the stories collaborate I feel they
wanted a conviction the lay the reason
oh yeah the reason why I kept in contact
with the victim why I made a reach
because at the end of the day it wasn't
the victim already Mia it was the biker
oh I feel you know I found out
a year later but I knew that all along
that Bella didn't talk first you know
they went to Vella at the hospital later
and said what happened he's like I don't
want to talk about it yeah and then days
later they went to him with how they see
with him what happened with him was he
was on BAM I'm in shock
listen to me he was on bail this dude I
kidnapped was on bail for having a GUI
going through a war with a car and when
they took him to the hospital get
stitched up while he was at the hospital
he clicked in the pharmacy and he robbed
like the cocaine far so they pressure
him with that I got you now you follow
me they said to him will ya testify
against him yeah you're done we got shot
of this a my head our whole hell done at
the end he and I go to court
yeah let's say what he did but he just
went to court and kept it like he didn't
really say nothing and then I bumped
into him so this is I what I did my time
in 88 I bump into him in 93 I had a bar
in Boulder Colorado yeah the bar and I
go what's up he didn't do this injury
this one Colorado what my time yeah yeah
okay okay my bad yeah I'm go ahead I'm
at the bar and I bought bento
I know how you doing okay give him a
package and while he's weighing the [ __ ]
in the hallway he's looking at me going
I can't believe you can't trust anymore
and all this [ __ ] the way that out and
gave it to me and that was it right so I
thought we were cool so when all this
social media popped up I thought about
him and I reached out to him and bro for
like two or three years he wouldn't go
back and then finally one day his armor
cracking he's like [ __ ] you you fat
[ __ ] you kidnapped me you ruined
my day you know all this [ __ ] yeah
that's some cred and I hit him back and
kept hitting him and finally he would
loosen up a little bit finally I know
this is my number and he call finally so
I got it off my chest you know I'm
saying I'm not if he goes to Tempe I'm
gonna bring him onstage to tell the
stone
he'll tell the story come on people what
happened yeah yes strain while I set you
up hey y'all I set you up
that's what I was taking the whole time
I was like well people don't understand
imagine kidnapping somebody he's like yo
man I'm cool he did hurt me eight like I
was I was in the trunk like you
kidnapped this fool and he was on bail
imagine being on bail you like I'm
freeing like some dude this grabs and
throws you in the [ __ ] truck he was
going through how like he was going
through how I got everything I deserved
in that stuff because I just took
advantage of this poor [ __ ] guy like
he was going through hell and when he
came through the using on my roommate
because his whole plot was he was
robbing his roommate yeah for the dude
who loved him stainless counter he got
on the jail and bailed them out that's
what he was robbing like this guy's just
crazy [ __ ] this guy's crazy yeah I'm
like your family if you're gonna rob him
then I'm gonna rob you
why am I gonna give you the cash if
you're gonna rob it that's how I looked
at ya is bullying too as well as I yo
doc you're a my block no he wasn't
getting bully he was he's a big guy he
was you had a paw a pistol these days
these guys you gotta pull out a pistol
it's [ __ ] crazy bro when I think
about all that craziness yeah I
physically got a different life it's
like I died and came back yeah that and
that was like a different [ __ ] life
about 30 years ago all that craziness
yeah you know this last time I was
locked up I talked to recent enemies
because when you're in there your
enemies are now your homies there's no
more set trip and it's like and there is
this dude that I jumped like I didn't
jump on this foot walked up to my cousin
was like I'm not [ __ ] kill you [ __ ]
and he didn't know she she had five
dudes outside so we went in there Joey
we were it was at 7/11 it was an orange
off of Maine right off of Maine in our
la vida
after a mary-jane girls concert and
these fools were from I won't say where
they're from but they're from Santana
and dawg we beat the [ __ ] out of these
fools like I threw that football a
Slurpee machine stomped on and [ __ ] and
and it was crazy cuz like back at this
time Lee like gangster movies was in boy
in the hood [ __ ] colors American me
Boulevard nights bound by honor blood in
blood out I was like I wanted I was like
trying to reenact the scene I seen in
there are you allowed to go into
7-elevens anymore yeah there was no
cameras back then oh this is before that
thank goodness we threw one of those
[ __ ] through the window Lee Oh
what window the front window oh Jesus we
were some leg
we were some crazy fools cuz I was from
like a hood that was like we were all
the guys that got cut from the varsity
team just cuz we didn't give a [ __ ] but
we still had game we were still with it
you know I'm saying I didn't have game
uh it was just it was in a different
area right yeah so you know what I mean
Joey
thug you're not the [ __ ] break it
down for me I said here some nights I
just [ __ ] wake up in the middle of
night I think of something dog this
should trip me right now like I didn't
know you kidnapped the [ __ ]
fool that was on bail that's crazy was
on bail
dan yeah that's a movie dog and the
other guy was a biker Frank like that
yeah that's a movie kidnapped em because
he was dating a stripper that was
divorced that trying to get divorced so
he moved the stripper intense love this
house he moved out of the bedroom order
into a bed nobody slept on the couch
the mother sucked on the other master
bedroom and I would go Ted why are you
[ __ ] him and he goes no no she's a
Catholic girl me well she was a titty
dancer she danced nude you know she was
making thousands and I have pressure she
was Catholic
she was Friday so she told him I'll [ __ ]
you you're my man but you have to pay
for my divorce oh you know how strippers
come on they with it that like I thought
about the deal real quick too she was
beautiful
yeah was a spanish girl it was beautiful
he was big white and dumb and stupidly
fell for the hook and that all that's
why he kidnapped this guy but he didn't
even do it for him he did it because he
needed that money to pay for a divorce
so she could be with him now
that's a you don't understand what what
Joey just said right now I hear that
read a [ __ ] daily these [ __ ] come
up to me and give it to and it's crazy
Lee because the only [ __ ] that
can scam strippers are hardcore gang
members this stripper was like a man my
full that I was with he got locked up
she's like I already sent him a thousand
dollars George
I sent him two packages I even sent
packages to his homies that are in there
and I was like you're getting [ __ ]
played homegirl I've been that dude but
she's like but he [ __ ] good a [ __ ]
every day like this girl's like yeah man
I'm gonna bone down for for three months
and he said he's gonna buy me tits and
an ass and what they do is that in TJ
the doctors in TJ Joey have stepped
their [ __ ] game up like they came to
San Diego and they got their degrees and
said you know what I'm still a [ __ ]
citizen to TJ I'm starting to my [ __ ]
over here they do what San Diego does
and TJ they do it for half - yeah
exactly
and you gotta put the deposit in she's
like you put cuz she got her tits she's
taking the fat off her stomach and
putting it in her ass so it's like a
better look and then she's getting her
tits all fixed up and [ __ ] and I think
it's why costing her four and five
thousand dollars that's all that's all
solve a guy smooth
he gave her twelve hundred he's like
I'll give you he said he's gonna give
her twelve hundred and increments of
those three months and he's like I'm
gonna [ __ ] when I want to [ __ ] and
that's it but the girls like okay yeah
yeah that deals in play but you still
gotta be my customer you still gotta
come in this [ __ ] tip me give me my
money because I still have to work I
can't just [ __ ] you when you want I'm
saying
so this fool comes into work pays the
[ __ ] at work that we watch on the
cameras this [ __ ] is getting [ __ ] did
you give them a discount or no no
because they have to the club always
gets two we have to know what you're
making like like say a half-hour costs
box the that's what it costs yeah you
we're taking you dog so I have found
notes oh dude 300 bucks to [ __ ] or the
[ __ ] okay I thought the lap dance with
everything with the rash anything but
it's still a lot Jesus Christ
yeah they'll piss on you leave I don't
want them yeah yeah how much like of the
pack how much you have to give them to
not piss on me yeah the whole package
what they [ __ ] you [ __ ] you they pee on
you I'll give you a brownie I don't know
soli like the club has to get that 300
and they take a fifty out and they give
you 250 back because you're paying for
that space you're using when you when
you [ __ ] at a strip club your pain to be
like all right this is gonna be done
quick there's no hotel there's nothing
it's just me going in somewhere I'm
[ __ ] and I'm out okay if you give the
full 30 minutes or is it just like after
this is over we're done it matters how
much that that's when the negotiations
and girl goes well look I'll [ __ ] you
for ten minutes in there but if you pay
me more these fools don't get a cut of
what I'm making now that you don't even
have the tip none of that so like I
heard I've been to clubs I ain't gonna
lie like I don't [ __ ] but I go to see
the competition like to see what they're
doing I always go to industry and I'm
like wow search yeah hey these [ __ ]
are only charging 450 to [ __ ] for half
an hour and I'm talking twenty
three-year-old the 28 year old only and
they're beautiful and it's like it's the
[ __ ] og pimping brothel house to the
finest because you know cholos run it
it's all sharp and sure they got candles
everything's clean sharp drapes curtains
you like hit somewhere they got like old
theater curtains that [ __ ] people are
[ __ ] those are sound barrier curtains
[ __ ] 55 years old I know I would love
to take my dick out there like apartment
building this [ __ ] but whatever
there's so [ __ ] disgusting it is it
really [ __ ] this disgusting as much
as much as you want to sweet love listen
everybody should try it one time try
wait what go to a strip club
oh there's a girl show with a chick and
[ __ ] her right there oh yeah
and let us suck your dick in the boot
you got to do at least one time in your
life yeah give us a [ __ ] yeah that's
what it's 300 bucks is for her to never
talk to you again with a 300 to swallow
you jizz I do what everyone wanna get
you can live your life you ever get a
rash it's on you you took a chance
Columbus dude who cares that's it I'll
take an uppercut for fun more but it's
how you feel after that it's how you
feel when you get home and you're like
oh my god yeah I just paid a chick to
suck my balls and she did it for 10
minutes you gypped me but I came because
every time I say anyway yeah when you're
come you're done you're done you're done
cuz your pants are all wet now you're
half-hour a minute so what happens like
are you really saying we have to tip
after that yeah it'll work the
negotiation see but you know what the
best part of it dawg
this is that how are you customers out
there this is how you win guys you could
be like look this is not a whorehouse
you guys told me the VIPs 300 bucks
there's 300 bucks well if I pay more now
I'm paying for prostitution if I that's
what this one fool did to us over like
damn all right dawg sorry homegirl like
if if you are out say you're the bouncer
and you go get that money you're now the
pimp because you're negotiating this
deal that's where they get you the club
can only be lay a that it says 300 on
the board sorry I'm all like but then if
the bouncer gets the money that's where
you get the extra tip it's pretty crazy
though cuz like some girls a lot of
girls don't con you they'll be like
they'll be like hey yeah we'll have sex
and they'll take you back there and the
big oh you don't have a condom you're
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] like I thought
it came with a deal and they'll come
back you better
have you 500 and she didn't give me no
sex and I was like if you didn't [ __ ]
homegirl you got to get that money back
because these are paying customers we
want them to come back to you know like
it's weird Joey like the girls will try
to get them and that customer will get
that 200 back and be like you [ __ ] up
it's now I'm gonna go get your friend
and spend a thousand on her because
these fools are in there to show off its
weird some weird [ __ ]
they sort of food at your place and all
they serve [ __ ] you you can't serve
food and [ __ ] in the same place really
hello that's a health code yeah I'm sure
I'm sure the health department really
know there's been like that when you
first go to Cleveland in Prague the
first time you work in Cleveland as a
featurette uh-huh
when you walk in the door you walk back
there they give you the keys to the
condo and on the way out the door guy
that answers the phone hey man hit and
he'll give you ten passes for free lunch
and there was a strip club a hundred
yards from the condo under the [ __ ]
bridge by the water and you were going
there at lunchtime at that prime rib so
you were there you got a lap dance for
the small 20 and yay some [ __ ]
horrible place however the meat looked
on Monday and looked the same on Tuesday
and they just put it like in a closet
and chopped loved it was hardly the [ __ ]
well I went the first day there was a
chef by Friday he just had a stripper
cousin had all this [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] crazy yeah no I've been
to strip clubs where they had food no
buck-naked full naked I don't think they
do full make it they do topless because
there's no there's one and uh there's
one called the library Joey we hey this
club is so good it used to be owned by
hustler and they bottom out they got
this method
these [ __ ] serve sushi in the
strip club on top of Nick deliver in
that place no I like they do it they got
a sushi chef back there like this is a
business spot there's like 50 girls
there on a Tuesday and they got a $3
anything like it's more couples there
than anything
fools of money just trying to get
[ __ ] horny it cracks it's classy
well it's or the [ __ ] if you got the
right right in there it's like you're
paying seven hundred up cuz yeah for
what for half an hour yeah right
upstairs yeah together suck you suck you
look this they got a sucky sucky [ __ ]
duck everyone does
everyone does if the price is always a
man those are the plate you give the
bouncer 100 bucks he'd be like hey
though you want me to park your car to
like you know I mean it's [ __ ]
are trying to get their money on wait
what if you given the bounce of like 20
bucks we give you an extra 10 minutes I
want a few weeks ago to a strip club for
like 30 minutes and I get through jeez I
knew man I really want to be that guy
people are like people don't go to strip
clubs in the valley at all like up in
the valley it's like [ __ ] - Russian
dude and a creepy Mexican dude that's
[ __ ] kidney ants oh [ __ ] anybody oh
my god he just goes and then they search
you at this troop like Jesus Christ yeah
I don't wanna be nowhere I get [ __ ]
search alright
you know I'm over all that [ __ ] guys I
feel now this I went to one this last
Thursday was psych dick eighties
birthday and we went to the house of
Eden and this one's different man cuz
this one's more of a dominant black girl
club it's like it's known to have
hot-ass black chicks and everything else
but the black chicks they're like they
run that [ __ ] and we went hard dog if
it's weird though because I don't know
how to say this one chick was like a man
like after like she tried to tell me she
trains in [ __ ] she's a AI I try to be a
Marine what the [ __ ] you know how
strippers trying to spill game and she's
like hey look the lap dances here only
cost 20 bucks no 10 bucks she's like if
you get three of them I'll let you punch
me in the stomach forty percent after
what
I'm not lying my son was there I'm not
my son trip that on me I was like you
swear to God I could punch you about 40%
she was that yeah all right was told
about that
oh hey I'll take you down you can meet
her not only be nobody so better but but
the Christian lead back in the room you
[ __ ] bunch of women of the stomach and
next thing another rehab will Harvey
Weinstein there's a reactions let me get
some shout out share real quick my main
man
Adam Milan who sent us some [ __ ]
flutes made on a wood they're beautiful
when I go to the jungle Larry Ziegler
Kevin Arnold mister yeah Sparky mega
Rees Anthony I Feliz Freddie da da
sherry Robeck Dante Kazee nee John J
Ramirez don't forget Thursday night
Tempe coming in big thousand milligram
brownies this [ __ ] right off the [ __ ]
airplane like I like a [ __ ] Airborne
Ranger you understand me and then the
third week of May I'm in [ __ ] the
stress factory Jersey I'm coming home
two days don't [ __ ] around
alright so let me ask you something when
did you shoot taco shop I think we shot
in 2010 no 2011 can you believe it takes
[ __ ] six years yeah you're off the
ground like after you shoot it
yeah like hey I was pissed like I'm ever
talking [ __ ] I'm mad we all get pissed
yeah y'all get pissed because they kept
telling us it's good to make it and I
was like come on now it's been five
years I was like you guys gonna change
the name to Taco flop like what the [ __ ]
dog like and finally Oscar Torino the
guy who wrote the movie he was like look
we're having a [ __ ]
we're having a viewing they got a fancy
hotel in LA and they had corrupt and
dads from the dog pound they're like we
got new investors they had run our tests
from the Lakers there so these new
investors took over and it was like okay
now it's moving you know and it got
picked up it's gonna be in select
theaters
it's gonna be on video on demand and
then in target so we'll see what's up
with it it's funny how sometimes you
shoot a movies like I had Rambo there
was a problem they shot Rambo seriously
the first one for him yeah there was a
problem with they shot it and then they
released it and they re released it cuz
it didn't have any heat oh I really
still have to Rocky as a wrap like it's
it's it yes exactly how you said him
that's it's really weird how film was
work how I did this movie years ago that
changed my life but I'm still a little
pissed off at the dudes because while we
were shooting we were gonna be on
Broadway we were gonna do this we're
gonna do that I think the movie came out
it called everybody like dog do you know
anybody in youtube you know anybody you
like Wow
we worked for three weeks around this
movie no days off three weeks [ __ ]
strain this movie right through
Thanksgiving I'm not mad about the work
I had a good time making it laughing but
it's the [ __ ] that goes afterward for a
while there bro after longest shot I was
doing [ __ ] I did like three years of
death I didn't move ease that will
[ __ ] god-awful that great to Walmart
bro straight to [ __ ] Walmart I didn't
[ __ ] know ya know when you're she
yeah hey you and you take the money and
then they call you up when they tell you
they having a premiere on Sunset
Boulevard is five o'clock on a Friday
afternoon you like what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] to do all my drugs and
son said Friday had a [ __ ] five
o'clock in the afternoon coming I did a
bunch of those for a while you know you
when you hear you you don't know what
issued you don't know what your [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know what I was shooting I was
shoots by the man - I don't know long as
y'all read Matthew [ __ ] but there's
movies that you shoot Ewing yeah I was
gonna happen here yeah I got two of
those under my belt you pray for the
best you know what's gonna happen
one of them I'm glad didn't [ __ ] make
it these [ __ ] flew me out to
Kansas it was Hutchinson Joey Chawla
like me it was I was in shock I thought
they're gonna kill me cuz like these
were like crazy white boys like a the
these were 35 year old men
they had on SpongeBob t-shirts at the
[ __ ] bar Oh dog you know the
spongebob they had those t-shirts and
[ __ ] and uh yeah
Kansas hey what were we saying right now
about the edible jump that you relax the
owner but look we got this oh yeah I was
talking about the part so they had me
putting a [ __ ] rapist like that I
guess there's a story in Kansas where
there's this um there was this rich ass
guy that restored anything antique and
he hired these two a cholo and a white
boy I just got out of prison because
they took woodshop and all that [ __ ] in
prison and they could repair anything
and I guess me my character and the
white boy we would rape the people that
came back in when they paid and it was
weird because it was the directors
girlfriend was the lead chick and he was
a a homie you're not even raping her dog
like what the [ __ ] is I want you to grab
her and throw her and I was like I can't
be doing that [ __ ] dawg I was on parole
I needed the money
I saw the reason I did it and now that's
what we do most of the dumb shall we do
I'm getting is for [ __ ] money you
know I'm glad that [ __ ] never
made it oh my god if I tell you how many
bad things I did for money yeah in
December especially cuz in December you
crumble yeah you know yeah they nation
of those type of deals show up in
December
it's December is do what you don't want
to do month if you don't want to do it
like so be broke when ya got hit in the
face with a pie no I was 1,500 yeah but
two hours cash in an envelope no ego
nothing
how many pies it before I still see the
guy every six months man we got release
it don't you like a bug it was in this
the guy who wrote the movie was supposed
to be a writer on a Seinfeld this is
when sign throw first [ __ ] ended they
called me in for this [ __ ] secretive
project that the meat meat pen D
whatever he's a writer on the side
tongue like I was smoking a cigarette
like he was [ __ ] chop Kowski or
rutowski whatever that
famous and they auditioned me and then
later on they called back in the way
well we wanted to get hit in the face of
the pie there Pete's app I forget what
the [ __ ] pie it was was it warm and I
was like you don't break my nose no he's
famous [ __ ] but when I got that it may
be wearing a diaper
oh my god why they throw because they
throw up by the way in there like they
usually forgot to tell me that you're
gonna wear a diaper so I got there
something weird bro
this was weird [ __ ] up Studio City those
envelopes one of those [ __ ] cash and
well another call some time from a
friend of mine I know well he does you
want to make a thousand bucks I'm like
absolutely just come to this address or
they put Lahey was a video game or some
type of game I let this fat chick the
flowers all welcome yeah yeah Wow you
know yeah thousand bucks right you get a
check like that the next day you have to
overnight check to the farmhouse you're
crazy bro and they rip me off you know
they give me a thousand if they're
getting ten thousand yeah up you're off
straight up but you need the cash yep
you need the cash what the one year bra
is dying on the vine we got the call on
the Sunday afternoon
if a [ __ ] 2000 bucks first they
offered me a nickel and I go where is it
they're like it's in Bowen I don't know
I'm not driving out there for a nickel
for that [ __ ] yeah how embarrass the
table this yes so they called back and I
solicited give me the [ __ ] small mm
there's I'm the real deal I've been
movies a [ __ ] oh yeah she goes okay two
thousand dollars
and I drove to Orange County and had a
walking with a suit and they believed I
was a big [ __ ] that's how much I love
cocaine that like it was my house and
I'm good week but I did a bunch of [ __ ]
I remember one year George specifically
oh my god
I just hooked up with Terry I hope that
would Terry that July about that
November we move in together and I'm
living with Terry and you know me though
don't you
I'll give you broke 11 months a year
Christmastime you always want to be
straight when I was broke when I was
flat broken on the streets doing comedy
in the beginning all I wish for was one
thing to have a decent Christmas can we
at least have a decent holiday season 11
days give me 11 days of the year god
I'll fight like a [ __ ] savage the
rest of the year but make sure that I'm
covered because there was a lot of
Christmases that bro 84 83 then 85 there
is real hurt there was one Christmas
that destroyed the 84 act like an ass
right in the hotel room by myself damn
little that type of [ __ ] so but that's
all I ever asked for was those 11 days a
year to be straight give me a little
coke you know say a little coconut six
to get the party started till New Year's
and then New Year's Day you lie to
yourself install over one [ __ ] year
bro I'm dead broke I'm doing stand-up
about being bubble mom well I'm snoring
like a [ __ ] storm it's 2000 2001 I'm
out there four nights a week snored
seven nights a week doing comedy right
how old are you at this time
thirty-eight there you know damn
Saturdays I'm just going out there for
fun I know I seen your old headshot was
all headshot day you look like you were
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up dog that was known as
dirty four yeah bro that headshot this
is how that headshot went down
yeah I became a regular at the store on
a Sunday and that Monday I went to the
store any girl from but me so they told
me to come back on Tuesday and the whole
days Jeff didn't work on Tuesdays at
piano go yeah so a Spanish guy worked
there than delica half a [ __ ] mustache I
rolled up his [ __ ] and he would always
come up he always wore like hats he was
colorful you know I'm saying I don't
know if he was in the closet if he
wasn't but you want me to tell you
something brownie was a good ass chick
Donnell that's what's not talking when
Danny goes what's on your mind we would
he don't like he's a piano player you
know they walk out
store and they go on the bottom this is
my second day in LA Li remember what was
the lesson to excel if you commit the
universe states K well I'm here I become
a regular that Monday before the comedy
starting the call from my so-called
manager than an agent want to assign me
if I had a head shot me what the [ __ ] is
head shot what are you talking about
yeah I need a head shot immediately feed
a quantum of theatrical audition instead
great agent that meant the town of East
LA was telling this guy that he knows
all right do me a favor you what are you
living Oh Hollywood it was perfect I
live in Hollywood I still know more the
place was it was down the it was down
the block that was disgusting
restaurants that's still there it used
to be you ever see the movie American
pimp now American peppers are the Hughes
brothers film or something I don't quite
- I might there used to be a famous
hamburger stand on Sunset where they
used to be hookers and but that place
down the block from that what the [ __ ]
we talk on them is 2001 and there's like
a hooker out there this dog that do
girls come by my house 11 10 and he took
headshots a development that night and I
will know in the corner of La Brea and I
made 10 copies that was that pretty much
was that like five bucks in those days
it was like $3 a copy damn I love them
but I'd do it I said what can I do for
you know just be my friend and he did my
headshots those headshots there those
days agents were saying you know we're
rejecting those you have to have either
these three head people take your
photograph and then wait for hundreds of
pieces I was like [ __ ] you I had shots a
headshot [ __ ] yeah even then I know you
don't sucker me into photographers
[ __ ] you it was like a union highlight
everything yeah we've really cliquish it
[ __ ] no you have to have head shots from
all these five people and they would
give you the sheet of paper and that's
what you had to do your headshots worth
or not they were
take you but these two sisters took me
and they got me auditions and meaning
whatever they got me started but the
point of the story is that this dude
just approached me he didn't want to
suck my dick he was not come here oh he
was just straight-up gangster Spanish do
it he does I think you picked him on my
backyard that's what's up he did it for
ya there was an hour out of his time and
he made my [ __ ] day I'll never forget
that headshot that your uncle posted huh
that's that headshot Wow
that's my first there's only 10 copies
of the Henschel so it's like limited
edition yeah you see that headshot steal
it because no reason they're gonna think
I had that hash on top of that I got
headshots with a different photographer
huh but I had that I still have like
five of those the six of us because in
those days you take your resume and
staple it behind the head shot
okay I'll show you how to make copies of
your resume and then cut it to the size
of the exact size of the headshot it
couldn't leak over the sides it had to
be perfect so you have to do that staple
the corners and then you had to bring it
to a that's every two or three weeks to
refuel you know it was Cray was a
completely different world I was on top
of that [ __ ]
my agents never called me so we need
head shots that's the worst that can
happen to you in those days your agent
will call and say you need that shot now
you don't even find the dead shot yeah
all those headshot places I had a
[ __ ] business straight up god no but
it's a it's a different world and it's
good that this movie came out you got a
little light shine on your taco shop
again tomorrow night the Communists yeah
do the show if I get on a guest book I'm
sorry I'm shooting tomorrow and don't
worry yeah we're gonna show the movie
first so you know how many PI mourners
what time's it start it's gonna start at
8:30 we're gonna show the movie the
movies hour and five minutes and then
after that we're gonna do like 45 hour
comedy okay and then you know it's
Monday the comedies towards the best
they got kill Tony you know I mean they
got killed Tony and they got potluck as
well it's gonna be a packed night
tomorrow good for you enjoyed it always
hustling bro trying
breaks out of jail don't they see George
you let hold you what you let hold you
how many people you meet bro but then
the first two minutes they telling you
they were in prison
you'll meet those guys first off they
tell you you don't even need for them to
tell you yeah they were like a badger
harlot yeah
in my world it was a bump in the road
and you get back on the road straight up
that's all that is if you're really that
personal they say they are it's gonna be
a bumpy [ __ ] road you know saying
it's a bumpy road but if you let that
person they say they are you can prove
them wrong straighter than guys like you
and me dead we've moved a few people
wrong that's it I take pride in that
before anything mmm you know how they're
never gonna make it to felons whatever
doesn't matter what they push if you
wear it as a badge honor you're [ __ ]
dead if you just go that was something
that happened 30 years ago [ __ ] you you
know yeah [ __ ] you don't I paid my dues
yeah sorry I paid my taxes I did
everything I paid my back taxes I did
everything bro
now it's over you're right hey you
remember that quarterback from the
Chargers Ryan Leaf he was like yeah
biggest flop man yesterday I stayed up
for a little bit it was like 4:00 in the
morning then I did you know he got
locked up he did three years yeah yeah I
looked up a couple dollars in yeah but
like now he's like a [ __ ] big-time
rehab counselor now and it's crazy like
[ __ ] all off oxycontin it's just [ __ ]
crazy doc we live in a weird zone and
life I thought yeah listen you're at the
copies though you're at the Comedy Store
that's the Yankees Stadium yeah straight
up okay
the check you [ __ ] up Stadium let that
that's uh the old Boston was never a
little bit family that's Fenway you're
in Hydra leagues that's died you stayin
as Chavez Ravine that's that's
everything you're in the major leagues
and you know we started the podcast off
of a little Roseanne
we want Roseanne Roseanne got so
powerful by the time I got here you know
I had heard she was just like vicious
huh brother said she'd never work again
she pissed everybody off that much but
all those people got it and guess what
she's still around she became relevant
on social media you know oh yeah humbly
followers she's got she gained all kinds
of mother-father all kinds of people and
she got all FoxNews emails and she gave
she went right in the slick way she went
right into the back door the fact that
their pain their again
20 years later bro yeah take your hat
off to oh yeah says on Twitter whatever
who gives a [ __ ] you know think that
these people may be ruffling your
feathers what does she have to lose if
this show fails nothing it's now she
goes back to I don't know why if she
still has 200 million dollars left and
fifty thousand farms and grown mangoes
or something okay [ __ ] something you
know people have to realize that [ __ ]
that sometimes people just getting you
riled up for no [ __ ] reason and at
the end of the daily [ __ ] at the end of
the day you know what they're just
trying to get numbers on a [ __ ] TV i
and you buy into it whether it's frozen
or Conor McGregor all over the [ __ ]
[ __ ] a Kanye West Kanye West what
else move they make this is five white
dudes in the room go what's our next
move
what's the strategic move you don't
saying this is what they expect from you
they're throwing a jab at you what do
you expect from George is George gonna
counter it with a kick to the body or is
George gonna counter it by taking me
down you know these are the options you
weigh so what the [ __ ] knows me I'm my
my business you you mind your business
you need a spot you go home you see your
kids and you're trying to enjoy the
second chance life gave you and that's
it this this is this [ __ ] easy I want
to be in [ __ ] that I don't know bro I
don't give a [ __ ] I'd rather come in two
nights a week [ __ ] around when Lee smoke
some dope talk [ __ ] with a friend and go
home then be on a [ __ ] studio all day
our father a rat yeah no no you learned
what you want to do you learn how you
want to do it especially out here this
could go fast or this could go easy
meaning you have been around for a long
[ __ ] time you've been around long ass
time [ __ ] you bro
20 years watch it watch it one of the
most interesting lines in any movies
Apocalypse Now when you taste the acid
trip
and he's thinking to himself well he's
like you know what Charlie's in the bush
getting strong and I'm in here getting
weaker by the minute we've been in the
bush you know in the bush watching
watching everybody else [ __ ] get
famous you know we were here I saw
Gabriel hit yeah my man again no no no
I'm not saying nothing like that I'm
just saying you see the way people hit
you see the people who stayed on top
watched on the road I saw the people
that breezed through everybody Brown
they were on the road for 18 months and
that's it they bombed out their little
TV show them pan out for them yeah
that's why we were just talking about
this at lunch today I saw a little dork
chick from the comedy store D'Agostino
at Murray T and we were talking about
how old you see so many headlines that
come and go you see the people who do
stand-up until they get a TV show then
they drop out of stand-up and they try
to come back six years later dog and
then the same time now because you got
upstage you still got that muscle that's
no bueno no way no matter you're on TV
and that you got a gun stage four times
the [ __ ] week and you'll figure it
out if you really want to stand up
you'll figure it out you'll figure out
how to get out there one night or we get
two nights a week the fact that helps
you it helps you are people watching now
you're yeah especially today if you go
to the Comedy Store you're like a
[ __ ] rock star now at the Comedy
Store a lot of actors go there not to
judge yeah it's always [ __ ] now yeah
no no no it's a different [ __ ] place
a different [ __ ] home well George I
wish you a lot of luck with this movie
you don't care I got your back dawg I'm
happy you came on tonight and heat it
was gonna be a ho-hum down I go [ __ ]
let's get George Perez to promote his
[ __ ] thing thank I said if I get on a
guest book tomorrow early I will take a
shower starts at 8:00 yeah starts at
8:30
comedy star main room tomorrow look at
you read [ __ ] there were spots
at the world famous that's how we do it
best climbing stuff like I said Thursday
Friday Saturday Tempe Arizona then the
end of the month stress factory
Providence has already sold out you know
I love you [ __ ] savages
as usual we'll see you Wednesday Lisa
Ann what's going on with you tosser I'm
drunk good buddy yeah you look good
tremendous thing what'd your mother say
Tommy's the son
yeah she's not happening anyway who
gives a Frenchman [ __ ] I love you George
Perez Levesque - brother luck tomorrow
at the Comedy Store
I'll see you savages Thursday in the
Tempe improv League kick that [ __ ]
mule oh [ __ ] that's right I almost
forgot how the [ __ ] that's how stoned
ahead I almost forgot to read the ads he
was saying that's him you know you stole
to the ground good that brownie creeped
out my xxx was the horse with you yeah
he was all the way in the end for the
whole race and he just blew right past
us listen you heard me talk about me on
these and you know I'm a big believer in
their product the perfect bounce and a
comfortable fit every month now they
have new and exciting prints and they
arrive at your door and a little fun
back gotta fun back myself the other day
you never know what's in that listen me
on these lensing micro mode all in their
underwear all right it's a substantially
sourced natural soft fibers that starts
with beech wood trees and then that the
most amazing fabric you've ever
experienced the results have been
downright dreamy me and these
adventurous prints and designs all
limited-edition and new patterns are
released every few weeks on a rolling
basis it's unbelievable every like three
weeks I had a new pair of [ __ ] along the
way and this is a matching one for my
[ __ ] girlfriend you don't worry my
wife girl from what the [ __ ] am I
talking about yeah that's how I am me
undies has won a percent satisfaction
guarantee all right we have these
guarantees you'll love their undies or
your money back
now I'm telling you what I'm gonna do me
on these has a great offer for the
family here for any first-time purchases
when you purchase any me on these you
get 20% off and free shipping me and
these are so sure you're gonna love
their underwear they offer you 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
the first pair you get a full refund
it's that [ __ ] easier right it's a
no-brainer get 20% off pair are the most
comfortable unusual ever put on they
grip onto your nutsack they make your
ass feel tight and there's no sweat sack
when you go like those
white underwear nada now it's over 2018
he is shipped together not again you 20%
off your first pairs we gonna do and
free shipping and all the percent
guarantee you gotta do this alright go
to me on this comm slash Joey me undies
dot-com /join listen get your pair I
mean these you don't tweet me and say
Joey I'm happy I get me on this night
you're [ __ ] Savage alright number two
listen to me listen to me straight 66%
of men lose their hair by the age of 35
all right
it's the hairline ciliary starting to
move backwards any bald spots yet yes
how will you feel a year from now when
it's business as usual up there do you
want a bald spot to pop up or do you
want to do something about it first
do you want your hairline to recede or
do you want to do something about it
first
why do guys turn to weird solutions that
captain were doing all this stuff and
when they could turn medicine when they
can turn to medicine and science listen
it's a one stop for hems calm it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men you hear me
one-stop shop you ready hair loss skin
care sexual wellness men hear me on him
connects you with the real doctors
medical grade solution to treat hair
loss well-known generic equivalents to
name brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair no snake wall pills or
gas station counter supplements none
other than prescription solutions backed
by science no waiting rooms no walk with
doctor visits save hours by going to for
hems calm it's that easy and for a few
questions a doctor review it and they
can prescribe you products are shipped
directly you ready for this to your door
directly to your door all right directly
to your door me I'm starting to lose my
hair in the back I'm 55 years old
listen I'm luckily doing it worked while
I had well I needed it now I don't need
it right now but if I need this stuff
this is what I would go with lead you
should give it a shot Columbus did
because from what I've read about this
tremendous war heaviness this is what
I'll do alright your church family again
if you want to now I'll get your trial
month to him
for five hours today right now while
supplies last right now five hours today
for a month
our trial month while supplies last see
the website the full details this will
cost you $150 if you went to a doctor of
pharmacy go to for hems coms last Joey
you want to stop being more you want to
prevent them before it goes crazy
that's for hims fo r h IM s.com slash
Joey for hindsight for hims calm slash
Joey anyway George Perez good luck
tomorrow night Thank You Lee Sang out I
love you dirty bastard you know ver they
giggling and you guys I love you I'll
see you in Tempe Thursday night don't
forget about me kick that mule Lee